- Les paysage e e e e e e e e ea
beaucoup pour plaire à ceux qui,
peut-être plus que jamais, ontgs
simple, proche de la nature et
de ses voisins. Mais ce village
d'à peine 600 âmes à s'offrir ur
convenable pour son petit café
au coeur de la bourgade.
LAURENT NICOLLE, conseiller
municipal, Fercé-sur-Sarthe
- Il
lorsque l'aubergiste est parti,
la mairie a racheté les murs
de l'auberge, et donc a cherché
des gérants qui puissent faire
vi
un certain nombre de... allez,
appelons ça de déboires.
- Fercé s'est donc tourné
vers un programme porté
par une association active
dans leset environnemental. Aven
programme des 1000 cafés,
l'organisation SOS veut rendre
aux campagnes françaises un peu.
un village dortoir. Donc, si on
n'a pas de cend'd'd'attraction,
de centre de vie dans
le village, eh bien, c'est çaau!
- Entre alors en scène Gwénaëlle
de vivre autrement.
GWÉNAËLLE LE GALÈ
O'Bout du pont
- Lui avait envie d'un petit
connaître le nom... le prénom
de tous ses clientrarararaiment
que ce soit à taille humaine.
Et du coup, quand on a commencé
petits villages, on ne savait
pas trop où s'ar,r,r,r, qui en
avait besoin. Et on est tombé
sur la page 1000 cafés, où il
on a dit : "Bien, en fait, c'est
exactement ça quererererche."
- Après quelques visites
infructueuses d'autres villages
en quête d'un tenancier de café,
le couple a été charhehehehehehe
villages et petits commerçants,
c'est bien de séduction
dont on parle.
MARION LE BLAY
- Oui, oui. Non, et ils sont
accueillants, chaleureux.
Ce n'est pas comme... Avant,
qu'on avait avant, c'était
différent. Donc, là, il y a
l'épicerie aussi. Avant, il
n'y avait pas. Donc, bon, bien,
ça crée aussi des liens. On peut
lui demander : "Bien, tiens,
est-ce que... Il n'y a pas ça?"
la semaine prochaine."
"OK, je teçaçaçaçaça comme
pommes", ou... Enfin, voilà,
ils sont ouverts à tout.
- Au dépar, , , , , , quand on a
ouvert en janvier, on ne faisait
que épicerie. Donc, ça veut
les produits de dépannage,
mais aussipapapapapapas mal
de produits petits producteurs.
C'est ce qui part souvent
locaux. On fait Mondial Relay,
donc un isisisisisis.
On fait dépôt de pains
pour une boulangerie
- Malgré une ouverture en pleine
, , , , , , Gwen et Phil ont su
développer une fidèle clientèle
de visiteurs assidus. Plus que
des amis. Sylvain Rouillonvevevs
sa Sarthe natale après avoir
enchaîné plusieurs contrat
c'est un peu chez lui.N N N N NN
- Des fois, je viens avec mes
enfants. On en a des petits,irir
quelqu'un de 90 ans qui estraraa
voir un petit enfant de 5 ans
qui est en train de gambadvevevc
tout le monde. Et je trouve,e et
une bonne image de ce qu'est
une personne âgée. Et  n n n n r
coupe pas les liens sociaux, l e
de dynamique d'être avec
des enfants, de croiser
qui sont encore en activité,
des choses comme ça.
- Il n'y a même plus
de manifestations qui se passent
on est le seul point, vraiment,
du village,
on va dire.
découvrent à peine,
lalalalalalalalaisir.
CHRISTOPHE RAVAUX
- Quand il n'y a plus de petits
comme ça, c'est dommage. Mais
vevevevevevevevert, là, aujourd,
c'est super. C'est bien. Ha! ha!
J'aime bien le système de
- Génial, d'accord, mais est-ce
rentable? Sans l'investissement
de base offertlelelelelelelelelt
du pont n'aurait pas ouvert
ses portes. Gwénaëlle et Phil
sont pour l'instant salariés
de l'organisèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèe
leur passage ne sera pas
que de quelques saisons.
- On ne sait pas forcément
si c'estnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsne
comme ça de 600 habitants.
Donc, y mettre un investissement
de dépé,é,é,é,é,é,é,é,é,é,é,é,ét
du compte, voir O'Bout du pont,
si ça marche bien, que nous,rare
notre lieu de vie à n
Et puis, oui, on a un rayondedee
est notre rayon de soleil
sur Fercé. Même ed,d,d,d,d,d,d,,
Radio-Canada,                .